first uh that thing to try to fit it's
don't waste your time don't try to feel
like just be you and embrace that and
make like take advantage advantage of
your difference because that's gonna
like make you different with somebody
else so maybe that's like something that
I was trying to do like really hard it
will start it like I don't know like I'm
I was trying to wear things out like
were in in fashion maybe I was trying to
speak in a way maybe I was trying to
have my hair and my makeup and to do
music in a in a certain way that was
good for people to listen to I really
wanted no I didn't want it uh to be
judged for nothing like I was trying to
be perfect in all the ways because I was
just wanting for the people to like me
no matter what make everybody happy
exactly